welcome welcome welcome we're here with
Megan Fox talking about her powerful new
poetry book um which I have been
devouring pretty boys are poisonous
that's right it brings that side out in
me and when you read this this is this
feels
like a very long life lived of collected
thoughts and feelings um you know would
you ever consider reading one of these
and now not I would I would probably I
would rather you read it oh really yeah
is that that won't offend you even
though I've already done it I would love
you to do it I would love it
okay I've learned to look at the floor
when men speak to me I've stopped trying
to share Charming anecdotes over dinner
because you always finish them for me
and I certainly don't dare laugh at
anyone else's jokes not even your
closest friends because we've all seen
what happens when a smile creeps across
my lips that you didn't put there I put
on my shortest dress and my highest
heels so that you can show me off while
simultaneously keeping a possessive hand
around the back of my neck my will has
atrophied in my chest my feelings stick
in my throat never forming words I
forgot that I had a voice long before
you decided to become my
ventriloquist and somehow in spite of
your genuine Longing To Be Loved you
prefer it this way the poem is called
the art of becoming an accessory
I'm telling you it's so good
look thank you I appreciate that it's so
good it's so good this book is so
wonderful I can't wait to be I can't
wait to see it be the smash success that
it deserves to be and thank you for
bringing poetry back into the world
because boy I mean that's who I was when
I was a teenager rimo B
Pablo naruda like give it to me now
Bukowski Bowski all the way I poetry was
so vibrant and alive and thank you for
bringing the art of it back it's so good
it's so good thank you um I was watching
like Entertainment Tonight in my hotel
room and Brian Austin Green came on and
the father of your children and he spoke
so beautifully about you know being in
engaged and that you are all feeling
positive and optimistic and encouraging
of each other and I just thought that's
the message we're supposed to give our
kids yeah and you work on the stuff
because it's never perfect and easy it's
a long road to get there but you figure
out a
way to find the
gracefulness and the humor and the
realness in all of it in a way like it
was just I liked that tone and I
appreciate it and it encouraged me as a
co-parent yeah
who has no interest in doing anything
other than talking about the function
because it's there yeah did like you
know that made me happy when I saw that
yeah I think it's really important when
people separate to never ever disparage
the other parent or or even in a passive
aggressive way um leave make remarks or
I don't let anything in my energy like
that when I'm around my kids
because if I don't accept and love their
father I'm rejecting a part of them
because he's a part of who they are
always he's in their blood and he's in
their psyche and they they exist because
of him and so if I reject him I reject
them so I've always made a point to be
very loving with him and about him and
very accepting of of his I love sha I
love like their baby is so cute that's
how I feel like I'm so happy that gives
your children the freedom to be happy
because they don't have to carry the
burden of like a war between
parents yes yeah don't ever ever tear
down the other parent to your child ever
there's that isn't adult at all yeah
it's incredibly childish and very very
damaging all right so we have to go to
the commercial break I we'll be right
back
[Music]